[Musique]
bonjour émission merci beaucoup de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous avez été relu dimanche
soir sénateur de Paris à la tête d'une
liste d'union de la gauche on va revenir
sur cette élection mais d'abord on parle
de l'actualité l'actualité de cette nuit
c'est sur 49-3 ce nouveau 49-3 déclenché
par Elisabeth borne sur le premier texte
de la session parlementaire la loi de
programmation des finances publiques la
première ministre dit nous avons 27 loi
nous ne pouvons pas prendre le moindre
risque candidats
le déclenchement de 49-3 puis c'est pas
seulement la saison du 49-3 qui commence
de toute façon c'est le quinquennat du
49-3 moi je suis frappé par la façon
dont
l'argumente le justifie la première
ministre d'abord en disant nous ne
pourrons pas prendre le moindre risque
forcément quand il y a un vote il y a un
risque de le perdre donc je pense que ça
n'est pas comme ça qu'il faut présenter
les choses ensuite du gouvernement qui a
lui-même décrété presque que il ne
pouvait pas percevoir les fonds
européens pour le plan de relance si il
n'y avait pas de loi de programmation
des finances publiques voter même si je
pense que c'est l'intérêt de la France
d'avoir une loi de programmation des
finances publiques pas celle-là et puis
enfin le 49-3 le respect du Parlement
devrait au moins conduire le
gouvernement à laisser la discussion
parlementaire à l'Assemblée nationale se
faire et ne le déclencher qu'à la fin on
le déclenchant dès le début de la
discussion visiblement cette nuit à
l'Assemblée nationale ça montre le peu
de considération pour le Parlement qui a
le gouverneur ça veut dire que ici au
Sénat vous discuterez de ce texte vous
ferez des propositions et éventuellement
vous seriez prêt à trouver un accord
avec le gouvernement sur le dernier
point je n'y crois pas vu la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
nous l'avons déjà d'ailleurs discuter au
Sénat au Sénat il y a pas de 49-3 la
droite est par ailleurs très majoritaire
elle avait même l'an dernier aggravé la
copie du gouvernement nous avions voté
contre mais bien sûr nous discutons des
textes et d'ailleurs les députés de
gauche ça fait près à discuter mais
évidemment qu'ils ne peuvent pas voter
un tel texte si le gouvernement ne
trouve pas de compromis avec les
républicains pour le dire clairement il
n'a pas le choix il est obligé de
déclencher le 49-3 mais pourquoi ne pas
au moins laisser la discussion
parlementaire se faire complètement on
va revenir très vite sur les questions
budgétaires mais un mot sur l'autre
actualité hier on l'a vu c'est ce plan
de lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
qui a été présenté par Elisabeth borne
avec plusieurs mesures des brigades
dédiées dans les rectorats une saisine
systématique du procureur en cas de
signalement et la confiscation possible
du téléphone portable de l'auteur du
harcèlement est-ce que vous saluez la
mobilisation du Gouvernement sur ce
sujet je salue la mobilisation du
Gouvernement sur ce sujet si c'est
vraiment une mobilisation peut pas
reprocher en isolation nationale de ne
pas savoir communiquer
mais il faut pas que ça reste que de la
communication il faut qu'il y a
véritable changement d'approche
politiquement d'approche politique pour
vous en tout cas je pense qu'il y a une
volonté de changement et dans ce cas-là
il faut que nous l'accompions que nous
la soutenions mais aussi que nous
exigions qui est les moyens les
syndicats ont raison cette mobilisation
elle nécessite des moyens dans les
notamment des moyens humains dans
l'éducation nationale donc
on peut la prouver et aussi être
vigilant et en juger dans la durée on va
revenir aux questions budgétaires
puisque le gouvernement a présenté hier
en conseil des ministres le budget 2024
et Bruno Le Maire était auditionné dans
la foulée par les parlementaires il est
venu ici au Sénat on va voir les temps
forts de cette audition avec notre
journaliste mathiasarez
[Musique]
Bruno Le Maire et Thomas Cazenave le
misent des comptes publics était donc
auditionné hier par la commission des
finances pour présenter le projet de loi
de finance absolument après avoir été
reçu par les députés c'est devant la
commission des finances des finances du
Sénat encore présidé par le socialiste
Claude rénal pour quelques temps que le
ministre de l'Économie et son ministre
délégué au compte public ont donc été
interrogés pendant presque deux heures
et c'est peu dire Oriane qu'ils ont été
reçus en terrain minet
puis six ans que vous êtes au finance
jamais vous n'avez baissé la dépense
publique même en avant les mesures de
crise les dépenses publiques ont
augmenté à votre programmation
budgétaire jusqu'en 2027 elle est en
fait fondée sur une seule hypothèse
votre capacité à faire baisser la
dépense publique comme jusqu'à présent
aucun gouvernement n'est parvenu à le
faire
quelles sont les grandes orientations de
ce projet de loi de finance c'est un
budget 2024 très ambitieux qui nous
attend et dans son propos introductif
Bruno Le Maire a fixé trois objectifs
clairs au futur exercice comptable de la
France on l'écoute
le premier défi c'est maté l'inflation
définitivement
et c'est le défi le plus important
le deuxième défi c'est de désendetter le
pays et de réduire les déficits ce qui
est comme le premier président de la
Cour des comptes l'a rappelé à
l'impératif catégorique le troisième
défi c'est de dégager des marges de
manœuvre un moment où il est aussi
indispensable d'investir sur la
transition écologique mais aussi sur la
défense et la sécurité face au retour de
la guerre en Europe inventeur Dieu quoi
qu'il en coûte le gouvernement veut à
présent être le garant de la rigueur
économique du recentrage des aides au
ménage et aux entreprises mais aussi de
l'augmentation de certains budgets
ministériel alors c'est un numéro de
funambule qui s'annonce délicat pour le
gouvernement attention toutefois à des
prévisions de conjoncture économiques
telles que la croissance peut être un
peu trop optimiste prévient la Cour des
comptes qui était elle aussi auditionnée
le matin même par l'intermédiaire de son
premier président Pierre Mosco ici il y
avait une ambiance électrique dans la
salle et on l'a vu avec le rapporteur
général du budget c'est Jean-François
Husson et aussi toute une ramement une
ribambelle de sénateurs pratiquement une
heure de un question pour pour parler
sénateurs Bruno Le Maire ironisait
d'ailleurs en début de séance en
anticipant une fin d'audition aux
alentours de 21h30 bref réduction de la
TVA suppression de la tvae maintient du
taux du livret A une aide pour les
ménages pour l'achat de carburant la
zéro le zéro artificialisation nette le
prêt à taux zéro la liste est longue et
tous les sujets ont été mis sur la table
pour ce qui sera le gros chantier de
l'action du gouvernement à l'automne et
de son ministre de l'Économie Rémi Féro
je peux peut-être anticiper votre
réponse mais est-ce que ce budget 2024
il vous convainc non
et pour des raisons qui sont très
différentes de celles du rapporteur
général du budget Jean-François Husson
des républicains nos oppositions
montrent d'ailleurs que ouais
gouvernement
c'est un peu le budget de l'impossible
cette année
chaque année c'est plus difficile y
compris par les choix et les non choix
que fait le gouvernement qu'est-ce qui
est impossible alors c'est impossible de
faire à la fois un budget de
désendettement un budget d'ambition et
un budget de lutte contre l'inflation et
de protection des français quand on
refuse de mettre à contribution les plus
riches les patrimoines les grandes
entreprises c'est impossible de vouloir
appliquer par exemple le rapport
Pisani série dont on a beaucoup parlé
quand on veut mettre en oeuvre
le volet de dépenses sans se donner les
moyens de recettes que recommande le
rapport c'est cela qui est de plus en
plus difficile et ça doit nous inquiéter
parce que les inégalités sont très
fortes dans notre pays la distribution
des patrimoines est de plus en plus
inégalitaire parce que beaucoup de
grandes entreprises font des supers
profits que le gouvernement a refusé de
et puis d'un autre côté il y a des
Français dans les difficultés de pouvoir
d'achat on peut penser notamment aux
jeunes et puis il y a des services
publics qui ont absolument besoin de
moyens l'éducation l'hôpital et
évidemment la transition énergétique
écologique et les moyens sont bien
augmentation de budget de l'éducation
plus 7 milliards pour la transition
écologique également par rapport au
budget précédent c'est aussi une
présentation bien sûr qu'il y a la
volonté d'aller dans ce sens mais les
moyens non ils ne sont pas à la hauteur
des besoins il faut aussi le dire
clairement qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
prioriser selon vous parmi ce que vous
venez de citer il y a quand même plus de
3000 milliards de dettes c'est un
mauvais objectif de vouloir désendetter
le pays je pense que c'est un bon
objectif de vouloir maîtriser cette
endettement et en effet il y a un
contexte qui change avec l'augmentation
des taux d'intérêt donc l'augmentation
du coût de la dette et la Cour des
comptes le montre très clairement mais
il faut regarder l'ensemble du budget
pas seulement les dépenses aussi les
recettes il faut aussi renoncer à des
baisses d'impôts qui ne sont pas
nécessaires comme la suppression de la
CVAE c'est-à-dire l'impôt qui est versée
par les entreprises aux collectivités
locales il faut aussi aller plus vite
elle échelonnée oui ce qui ne fait pas
plaisir au patron mais c'est une demi
politique c'est une demi-mesure du coup
tout le monde est mécontent s'il était
chelonné c'est parce que c'est une
mauvaise mesure
ça rentre dans une politique de l'offre
à l'oeuvre depuis 2017 et qui
aujourd'hui est complètement caduque
mais le gouvernement n'arrive pas
vraiment à y renoncer la philosophie du
gouvernement c'est pas d'augmentation
d'impôts est-ce que vous dites il faut
renoncer à cette philosophie il faut
augmenter des impôts pas n'importe
lesquels d'abord il faut renoncer à des
pestes d'impôts qui ne sont pas
justifiés et qui prive l'état de
ressources publiques dont les Français
ont besoin pour leur service public et
dont les grandes politiques ont besoin
et ensuite ensuite il faut savoir
augmenter les impôts même limiter dans
le temps sur ce qui le peuvent et je
pense notamment nous l'année dernière on
s'est battus pour la taxation des super
profits on s'est battus pour la taxation
des sociétés d'autoroute et c'est le
gouvernement qui nous a dit non
d'ailleurs dans votre sens sur la
taxation des sociétés d'autoroute un an
après que de temps perdu mais le temps
perdu c'est aussi des recettes perdues
mais je ne désespère pas quand je vois
les centristes au Sénat qui veulent
revenir cette année encore sur la
taxation des super profits si nous
avions à dégager une majorité en ce sens
mais ce sera une victoire politique
j'espère que le gouvernement arrivera à
nous entendre je pense que la période
devrait permettre à chacun le
gouvernement et la droite sénatoriale
aussi te remettre en cause un certain
nombre de dogmes et d'être plus souple
pour permettre des nouvelles ressources
qui permettent de financer les
politiques qui en ont besoin on a
l'impression que c'est un budget qui ne
satisfait ni la gauche ni la droite
alors quelle méthode adopter me souviens
tous des des débats animés à la même
période l'année dernière et notamment à
l'Assemblée nationale ou le gouvernement
n'a pas pu envisager notre stratégie que
celle du 49-3 finalement comment faire
comment réussir à adopter la France d'un
budget cette année mais au gouvernement
n'a pas de majorité politique à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est le résultat
des élections législatives il n'y a pour
autant pas de contre majorité donc je
crois que Boris Vallaud le disait tout à
l'heure c'est la saison du 49-3 qui
s'ouvre je pense qu'il peut y avoir
quand même de la part du gouvernement un
respect du temps de la discussion
parlementaire et dans le déclenchement
du 49-3 la prise en compte d'un certain
nombre d'amendements votés et puis le
gouvernement pourrait aussi rectifier sa
trajectoire notamment sur les recettes
sur les moyens qui sont donnés laissés
aux collectivités locales sur les moyens
qui sont donnés aux grandes polit un
public le 49-3 il pourrait aussi le
concevoir comme autre chose qu'un coup
prêt et là je vois vraiment un
gouvernement très rigide sur ce point
vous avez additionné Pierre Moscovici
hier également le président de Haut
Conseil des finances publiques alors il
dit que l'hypothèse de croissance est
élevée mais pas une atteignable et en
revanche que la prévision déficit est un
peu optimiste est-ce qu'il y a une forme
d'un sincérité dans ce budget Pierre
Moscovici a dit je ne veux pas utiliser
le mot d'ins sincérité est-ce que vous
vous l'utilisez tout dépend le sens
qu'on lui donne il utilise pas non plus
le mot de sincérité dit que toutes les
hypothèses sont optimistes et je
tous les chiffres lui donnent raison il
y a de quoi être inquiet que de prendre
uniquement les hypothèses les plus
optimistes dans tous les domaines ça
justifiera peut-être nécessitera
peut-être de revoir ce budget en cours
d'année
je pense que le gouvernement fait ça
pour essayer de résoudre son équation
aujourd'hui mais personne n'est dupe et
c'est bien que la Cour des comptes mette
l'alerte c'est son rôle et que les
parlementaires l'écoutent un dernier mot
sur ce sujet rémission puisque le Sénat
renouvelle en ce moment c'est postes
clés après les sénatoriales est-ce que
vous vous êtes candidats pour prendre la
tête de la commission des finances
présentes pas candidature au sein du
groupe socialiste d'abord puisque les
socialistes étant le premier groupe
d'opposition la présidence de la
commission et des Finances leur revient
c'est un choix que feront l'ensemble de
mes collègues du groupe en début de la
semaine prochaine mais vous êtes
candidat on va remercier Mathias
et on va parler de l'actualité chez vous
à Paris Rémy ferrot on trouve Jacques
Pâquier directeur de la rédaction du
journal du Grand Paris bonjour Jacques
merci d'être avec nous vous souhaitiez
revenir sur la hausse de la taxe
foncière après la pique lancée dimanche
par Emmanuel Macron à certains maire
absolument bonjour monsieur le sénateur
après la pique lancée par par Emmanuel
Macron et puis après les propos de
Francis spinner sur votre sur votre
antenne
avant-hier qui disait monsieur Feraud
que finalement ça ne vous surprendra pas
la hausse de la taxe foncière est
principalement du selon lui à ce qu'il
appelle un train de vie de la ville de
Paris
au-dessus de ses moyens
une finalement une mauvaise gestion il a
il évoquait notamment la masse salariale
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez
que ça n'a évidemment rien à voir quand
on parle de train de vie c'est qu'on
c'est qu'on a plus rien à dire la masse
salariale ça n'a rien à voir avec le
train de vie la masse salariale ça avoir
avec le personnel de propreté les
personnels dans les crèches les
personnes dans les périscolaires dans
l'ensemble des services publics
municipaux c'est des personnels qui sont
au service des Parisiens et donc nous
menons en effet une politique de gauche
à Paris qui va avec le fait de
développer le service public et puis
aussi de transformer la ville parce
qu'il faut des investissements pour
adapter la ville au réchaud dérèglement
climatique et aussi lutter contre nous
nous l'assumons totalement nous le
revendiquons même ensuite les
collectivités locales sont privées de
ressources par l'État y compris c'est
pas seulement des dotations somme
empêcher de percevoir un certain nombre
de ressources on peut penser à la taxe
de séjour sur les nuitées hôtelières et
donc à partir de ce moment-là il n'y a
qu'une seule ressource que pas seulement
Paris mais toutes les communes de France
peuvent augmenter une seule c'est la
taxe foncière et donc Emmanuel Macron a
attaqué Anne Hidalgo la mère de Paris
dimanche soir dans son interview et il a
pris un boomerang de tous les maires de
France qui ont estimé qu'à travers ses
propos c'était l'ensemble des maires de
France qui était attaqués beaucoup
d'entre eux est en contraint d'augmenter
la taxe foncière cette année parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'autre choix pour
avoir des ressources nouvelles à Paris
on est sur une augmentation énorme qui
va qui est supérieur à 50%, est-ce que
vous comprenez que ça suscite la colère
des Parisiens d'abord je ne crois pas
que ça suscite la colère des Parisiens
doivent être mis en perspective Paris a
aujourd'hui la taxe foncière la plus
basse de France en taux et même après
cette augmentation elle reste la taxe
foncière la plus basse de France et nous
nous aurions préféré augmenter
d'autres impôts notamment je pense à la
taxe de séjour ne pas voir la
contribution des entreprises
diminuées même quasi supprimer par
l'État il faut voir dans quel contexte
les communes peuvent agir il est
extrêmement contraint par la politique
du gouvernement elle le conteste tout
monsieur Ferro juste une dernière
question je pense que la l'augmentation
de 52% de la taxe foncière génère une
recette un produit fiscal d'environ 800
millions d'euros Anne Hidalgo dit très
clairement que sans cette manne Paris
serait condamné à l'inaction notamment à
l'inaction climatique est-ce que sans
faire dans la caricature vous pourriez
nous nous imaginer illustrer finalement
l'usage que vous faites de cet effort
supplémentaire demandé aux Parisiens à
quoi à quoi va à quoi va servir va
servir pardon cet argent
fonctionnement des services publics
refus de les diminuer
soutien aux parisiens grâce à ces
ressources fiscales et bien le estarif
de cantine reste à leur niveau
le soutien pour payer le Pass Navigo
soit des personnes âgées soit des
enfants et ça compte pour les familles
peut être maintenue les tarifs de
cantine je crois que je l'ai dit ne sont
pas augmentés les tarifs de crèche non
plus c'est l'ensemble des tarifs pour
les familles qui ressemble maintenues le
périscolaire reste gratuit à Paris et
puis enfin les investissements pour la
transition
écologique peuvent être réalisés et même
accélérer c'est la transformation de
l'espace public
et puis c'est la rénovation énergétique
des logements des bâtiments il y a aussi
la dette climatique à laquelle il faut
penser et donc bien sûr que ça ne fait
jamais plaisir de devoir augmenter les
impôts bien sûr que la taxe foncière
touche tous les propriétaires quel que
soit leurs revenus même seront exonérés
ceux qui réalisent des travaux de mise
aux normes énergétiques mais c'est le
cadre dans lequel toutes les
collectivités de France doivent agir
elles n'ont pas assez de souplesse pour
pouvoir prélever les ressources qui
correspondent le mieux à leur territoire
et qui contribueraient le plus à la
justice sociale merci Jacques le paquet
merci
avec nous on regarde la Une du journal
du Grand Paris cette semaine il n'y a
revisite la place de l'architecte c'est
à la Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous on va revenir sur
les sénatoriales Rémi Féraud puisque
vous avez été réélu dimanche soir
sénateur de Paris à la tête d'une
mission de la gauche qui a fait
huitièges contre 4 pour la droite
parisienne qui a été attaqué par Anne
Hidalgo la droite parisienne qui
explique leur score par le spectacle de
la cite terrible souvent clooneesque
souvent dégradant donné par Rachida Dati
c'était opportun cette déclaration du
mancheur
et quand vous dites quatre sièges pour
la droite fin 3 sièges pour la liste de
Rachida Dati et un siège pour Agnès
evraine que Rachida Dati a essayé
d'empêcher de devenir sénatrice pour des
raisons d'ailleurs qui m'échappent donc
bien sûr peut pas un moment subir la
violence permanente des attaques
et parfois des clowns de de Rachida Dati
et un moment ne pas dire stop et ne pas
dire voilà la réalité des résultats
voilà la réalité du résultat de votre
forme d'opposition qui a cassé son
propre camp sans nuire du tout
finalement au résultat de la gauche
spinner il est pas comme vous Francis
piner il a été élu sénateur sur la liste
de Rachida Dati ne lis pas comme vous
les résultats il dit que ce sont eux qui
ont remporté l'élection parce qu'il y
aura quatre représentants des
républicains pour Paris au Sénat et qui
aura trois représentants et demi du PS
et que donc à l'hidalgo a perdu
on peut dire qu'il fait nuit en plein
jour je crois que c'est une analyse que
j'ai vu qui n'appartient qu'à lui à
laquelle il ne croit d'ailleurs lui-même
pas du tout toute la campagne a été fait
pour il faut sauver le soldat spinner au
sein de la droite parisienne qui s'est
déchirée comme vous me direz à chaque
élection mais encore plus et largement
du fait de la façon dont Rachida Dati
président
ils se sont divisés sur trois listes et
en effet ça fait quatre sièges de toute
façon les corps des grands électeurs et
ceux qui l'est l'important c'est que la
gauche est passée de 7 à 8 sièges et
qu'elle a su s'unir pour cela et moi je
suis très fier d'avoir conduit cette
liste de rassemblements et d'avoir
permis l'élection d'un sénateur de
gauche et écologiste de plus parce que
notre objectif c'était de participer au
regain de la gauche au Sénat que Paris
participe et c'est le cas
dangereuse pour la gauche en vue des
municipales
je pense que c'est surtout aujourd'hui
une chef dangereuse pour la droite et
c'est sénatorial le montrent et qui pour
succéder à Hidalgo
on verra quand arriveront les
municipales on n'est pas dans ce
temps-là ce n'est pas ce qu'elle a dit
elle a dit qu'elle dirait dans un an un
an et demi si elle se représente ou si
elle ne se représente pas et bien comme
ça c'est clair et ça permet de renvoyer
le temps des municipales autant des
municipales c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes amis mandat nous sommes dans
l'action la majorité municipale a des
différences il y a parfois des
divergences en interne mais on travaille
ensemble et on avance ensemble on va
revenir à ce qui s'est passé au Sénat
cette semaine dans votre groupe dans le
groupe socialiste il y avait l'élection
de votre président de groupe il y avait
deux candidats Patrick canaire le
président sortant qui est plutôt sur une
ligne en tenue et Eric et rouge qui lui
avait le soutien de l'évier fort c'est
Patrick canaire qui l'a emporté
finalement assez largement c'est l'échec
d'Olivier force qui s'est passé
je crois que c'est une lecture trop
simple et qui ne correspond pas
forcément ce qui se passe au Sénat
Patrick Henner a un bon bilan de
président de groupe il a permis au
groupe de se reconstruire et de se
projeter à nouveau et d'être dans une
opposition qui a marqué des points qui a
retrouvé aussi une audience c'est son
les socialistes au Sénat qui ont porté
proposition de constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG
de la nuque dans le choix de génère je
pense qu'il y a une part de cela mais
c'est trop résumé
les sénateurs socialistes n'ont pas vu
le besoin de changer de président alors
que justement nous sommes dans une
dynamique qui est positive pour le reste
nubspanup enfin
aucune des listes qui ont été présentées
dimanche dans aucun département
n'était une liste dans un cadre Nuxe
eric kerouche n'a pas revendiqué n'a pas
revendiqué ce mot donc justement la
France insoumise a été écartée de vos
alliances vous-même vous aviez une liste
avec socialisme communiste écologiste la
France insoumise qui vous accuse d'avoir
fait perdre 10 sièges à la gauche
sénatorial Candido non c'est tout le
contraire
d'ailleurs si c'était le cas il y aurait
bien eu des listes d'alliance avec elle
et si dans certains départements il y en
a une nulle part donc ça n'est pas le
sujet si à Paris nous étions présentés
avec elle et fille nous aurions perdu
des sièges
la France insoumise aujourd'hui pour les
élus locaux dans cette élection
sénatoriale
à l'évidence puisque d'ailleurs personne
n'a voulu faire de liste d'unions avec
eux et les amis d'Olivier fort non plus
au sein du Parti socialiste mais Marine
dondelier qui était à votre place
avant-hier elle nous disait qu'il aurait
au moins fallu leur laisser un siège au
Sénat pour ne pas les humilier est-ce
qu'elle n'a pas raison mais en tout cas
elle n'a pas fait
donc elle a répondu très content qu'il y
a pas de sénateur la France insoumise
pas le temps est très content mais c'est
qu'il n'avait pas les grands électeurs
pour avoir
des sénateurs mais parce qu'ils n'ont
pas cette implantation dans les
territoires et j'ai entendu cette parole
de marine tondeuse je me suis mais
pourquoi n'a-t-elle pas proposé que un
siège des verres soit pour la France
insoumise elle ne l'a pas fait j'ai
trouvé ça étonnant merci Rémy frérot
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi